are you going to eat that are you going
to the [ __ ] today we're playing the
whisper challenge this was popular
amongst youtubers a little bit ago but
the producers thought it was funny so
we're gonna do it now I'm Shelly Carlos
Carlos amazing that hi hey my name is
I'm Gia
I'm Michael nice to meet you it's nice
to meet you how is it is it loud enough
its piano I'm talking really loud now hi
yeah wiener penis what a rat cleans his
house with his tiny family something
house where our family is I would like a
monocle please can I murder you queer a
rat cleans his house with his tiny
family rent rat riot
rat like mice like best mice best mice
what I would like a monocle I kinda have
some watermelon
will you it was that a rat cleans his
house up with his hanging family well I
would like a monocle please you can't
what okay okay there is always a rainbow
after the storm you're bringing the
puppies down to the lake there's always
a rainbow after the tacos you didn't get
the [ __ ] out of my house Sally sells
seashells by the seashore santa salad
salad okay Sally there's always a
rainbow there's always a free boat
there's always
rainbow after after the storm storm
Sally sells sonny tells sells like Oh
type no no no Sally sells seashells by
the seashore
there's no he's a rainbow after the
storm later tonight I'm going to go get
vegan food that was really inappropriate
if you like me I would like a monocle
please oh god I really like bottles
please quotes clothes I feel like I'm
very loud you are noodles losers noodles
noodles you I I'm not getting this
noodles yes I would like I would like a
monocle a Gaga a bottle a bottle
noodles noodles noodles lose no you I
meet later tonight I'm gonna go get
vegan food and you we're gonna do coke
in the field it's a noodles noodles new
oh okay okay I would like a monocle oh
that was horrible
honesty it was fun it was like a
reminded me of the telephone yeah
I was only a whisper that in your ear
but exactly same concept it was quite
hard means you know one day I think it
was like a 88.5 from me
yeah the most fun was guessing what he
was saying because I literally had no
idea so I could just make up words it
was fun it was fun like that new best
friend yeah